Mr. Gorbachev, tear down this wall.
Major changes are now taking place
in the Soviet Union.
The Baltic peoples of Estonia, Latvia
and Lithuania will be free to
determine their own future.
Mingling with the rush hour traffic,
Red Army armored personnel carriers
on the streets of Moscow this morning.
Momentous events today.
The course of history is changed.
Mikhail Gorbachev resigned.
The Soviet Union collapsed 30 years ago
in part because its government-run
economy was incapable
of producing blue jeans,
cigarettes, and automobiles
that its citizens wanted.
What it was great at,
was producing champion chess players.
From the end of World War Two,
until the evil empire dissolved in 1991
all but one world champion,
the American Bobby Fisher,
represented the USSR.
None was better than Gary Kasparov,
who became the world champion in 1985
at the record, young age of 22.
Widely considered the
greatest chess player
in modern history,
he held that title for 15 years.
As a chess prodigy,
he traveled abroad for competitions
and he describes youthful
trips to France and Germany,
as nothing short of revelatory.
The casual abundance of what used
to be called the Free World,
just felt different, he says.
Beyond the iron curtain,
he encountered the anti-communist
works of George Orwell
and was able to read exile dissident,
Alexander Solzhenitsyn's
suppressed indictments
of totalitarianism.
As the eighties progressed,
he publicly questioned the Soviet system.
In 1990,
he joined the Democratic Party of Russia
and became increasingly outspoken
in favor of human rights,
representative democracy
and limited government.
In post-Soviet Russia,
he used this celebrity and
influence to spearhead attempts
to build civil society and
conduct fair elections,
emerging as a leading critic
of Russian leader, Vladimir Putin.
By the early 2010s,
he had been arrested for participating
in unauthorized
anti-government demonstrations
and was widely believed to be the author
of a popular petition
demanding Putin's resignation.
As chairman of the
Human Rights Foundation,
Kasparov continues to lobby for freedom
in the former Soviet Union and beyond.
In September,
Reason spoke with the chess
Grandmaster in New York
about what it was like
to be the beneficiary
of a catastrophically
failed Soviet system.
And what lessons the world,
especially American democratic
socialists should remember,
three decades after its collapse.